hey guys I'm here in Vegas and it is
extremely hot right now I can't even
tell you how hot it is because I don't
have a thermometer but we're here in the
front of wonderful Planet Hollywood
I'm also here with a special friend
where'd she go oh here she is
Aegis team is here how are you are you
having a good time in Vegas I just wanna
be on the internet I want to be typing I
shouldn't be behind the computer I don't
like this I don't like this is what it's
locked in this timer I'm wearing I just
want to be online where my friends are
I want to be typing this is I wanna play
online blackjack I might like poo oh
yeah uh-huh all right try it okay anyway
she's been having a little bit too much
fun in Vegas but anyways I'll see you
guys when I get back to San Francisco
have a good weekend
peace out